[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen hier ein
gugelhupf ich hoffe das war die richtige
der richtige programm kugelköpfe wir
machen wofür und zwar zitronen gruppe im
mini format und die sind super saftig
und gehen auch sehr sehr schnell und wir
gehen jetzt mal direkt über zu den
zutaten
wir benötigen mehl backpulver zucker
weiche butter zimmer war meier josi habe
ich 35 prozentigen und eine bio zitrone
so und dieser teig reicht für sechs mini
cooper ich bin dieses wort einfach so
witzig und wir starten jetzt in dem wir
die weiche butter zusammen mit dem
zucker drei minuten lang cremig rühren
dem ist mein handrührgerät damit auch
die küchenmaschine verwendet bei so
wenigen zutaten so eine riesenmaschine
das lohnt sich nicht
das ganz gut jetzt gute drei minuten
lande mixed und sieht so aus und ich
gehe jetzt noch die zimmer waren eier
dazu und es ist ganz wichtig dass ihr
zimmer waren sind sonst würden die sich
nicht so gut verbinden und danach könnt
ihr auch schon den abrieb der
zitronenschale nehmen und das ist auch
ganz wichtig ist mit bio zitrone ist
denn sonst wäre sie ja gespritzt sondern
habt ihr sachen dem tag die möchtet ihr
nicht glaubt mir kommt
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt backpulver und mehl ganz
grob miteinander verrührt und für diesen
tag müssen wir sie trocknen zutat nicht
das erübrigt sich hier denn es verbindet
sich sowieso und im nächsten schritt
gebe ich immer die trockenen zutaten und
abwechselnd in joghurt mit dazu bis es
sich alles schön miteinander verbunden
hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so beteiligt ist fertig das ging ja hoch
kiki und jetzt nehmen wir uns einfach
zwei löffel und durch füllen unsere form
damit ich habe jetzt eine silikonform
die muss man vorher nicht einführten je
nachdem was ihr da hast könnt ihr dann
aber schauen ob er das ganze einfetten
müsst und jetzt ganz einfach die sechs
förmchen befüllen in den ofen damit 180
grad ober unterhitze der ofen muss
vorgeheizt denn das ist ganz wichtig und
bedauert das ganze so gute 16 bis 18
minuten bis das goldbraun und gar ist
und jetzt müssen wir die google hofft
nun noch schön aufhübschen und dafür
machen wir einmal einen schnitt
schneiden das durch damit es auch so
schön gerade aussieht wissen wir was mir
aufgefallen ist es ist ja eigentlich
also von der seite in affing und von der
seite ein gugelhupf also 2 1 jetzt
möglich weiß was sie machen wie man
richtig klick baic im titel 2 1 eintritt
selbst eine sensation
nein lasst uns lieber also ganz einfach
durch schneiden und dann zeige ich euch
die zitronen glasur
[Musik]
sondern für das frosting wir
wahrscheinlich alle noch aus der
kindheit als allererstes dinge in meinem
leben als mit zehn jahren gemacht habe
dass es ganz einfach puderzucker und
zitronensaft und das ist noch die
zitrone von gerade und das einfach so
lange verrühren bis sie so eine richtig
schöne sich flüssige masse erhalten habt
[Musik]
also so in etwa sollte das runter
fließen und die abgekühlten google hoffe
die werden jetzt ganz einfach damit
bestrichen oder kuchen wird eben wenn
ihr möchtet könnt ihr dann noch bisschen
drauf geben für die farbe halb damit die
farbe auch stimmt
[Musik]
auch mal ein und die koreaner ja du kein
zwei jahren hatte man hier mit der
kamera
glaubst du bist du siehst du aus ja aber
du musst ein bisschen mehr drauf machen
will ist mir nach mehr ist mehr so meine
lieben ich hoffe dass ich das rezept
gefallen hat ihm müsse zum nachmachen
das war ich zwar immer aber es ist ja
wirklich nachmachen das ist total
sachlich zitronig und erfrischt ist
einfach also gerade erst jahreszeit
passt die genauen mengenangaben die
schreibe ich euch wie immer hier unten
in der infobox hinterlassen gerne euer
feedback da freue ich mich immer sehr
und natürlich ein dörfchen nach oben und
ein abo wenn du bist nicht abonniert
habe dann leute es höchste zeit so und
dann sehen wir uns auch im nächsten mal
auf die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]